uh sam do you want to play us in dude oh
i got the soul
okay with this deep bare tone
play us in with that brand new baritone
[Music]
oh yeah
yeah
get some of those vibes
[Music]
some of these thinker picking has gotten
better
sam paid the debt
that's right he's still a branded man
[Music]
hey i got a bit
dude yeah
we can officially start the podcast
that's a great way to start a bid is to
introduce it as a bit so for the last
month
i've been to 16 states
in the country and uh
by rv
suv etc
and
one thing you do when you're on road
trips is you stop uh you check your air
your tire pressure especially when
you're in like a large rv with high high
pressure in the tires because if the
pressure gets too low
the tires can blow
same thing if they get too high that's
what they say um so you got to keep them
right in the middle right so you want to
keep an eye on them so i was doing that
on this 3 000 mile road trip that we
were going on and um
i found that there's something very
particular about gas station air
uh pumps now
they all almost all
have
computer chips in them now
they're not the they're not the vending
machine style where you just put in the
quarter and then the pump kicks on and
it kicks on for like three minutes and
gives you the pressure
and you can pump however much air you
want into your tire
no now they have these deals where you
tell the computer in on the box what you
want your air pressure to be and then it
checks what your air pressure is
currently at and then it goes
and it does this automated process
to get you the exact air pressure that
that uh it needs but now this sounds
great right it sounds great so far so
good
on air pressure but the technology of
occam's razor
creates such that it's you're just
adding more complexity to something that
already worked
um and so the first problem that i ran
into is i was on i was in a 29 foot sc
or 29 foot rv which has semi-truck tires
on it
now these semi-truck tires have really
high air pressure oh yeah and and you
can't get the air pressure on these
automated deals higher than 80 because
it's like a liability thing now because
they added a chip and now it's doing the
work that the human was supposed to do
now it now you can't it won't let you
pump pressure higher than 80 because
it's like well why would you ever need
higher than 80 pressure
on your tires the tire is going to
explode that could be dangerous it could
kill somebody we could be liable wow
so now you can't do that and then of
course like only half of them work
as those machines normally
seems
yeah and then um
and then you have to like set the thing
and then it tells it instead of the
gauge right the little gauge you press
and then the thing slides out and it
tells you the tire pressure
now it now it's like no i'll tell you
when i'm at 35 psi and then so you fill
up your tire thinking that it's at 35 or
40 psi or whatever
and then you get in your car or you
check it with the actual gauge and it's
not at that
um and so yeah just just one of those
things like i'm not a luddite i'm all
about like you know the useful
advancement of technology for the sake
of humanity but like
was that one of the things we need like
is that actual progress do we do we need
to have computer chips in air pumps at
gas stations or are people not capable
of just like going my tires needs to be
40 psi
check
check okay it's at 40. it's like right
there in your hand not
10 feet behind you yeah
yeah and then like it's like it's like
no let us tell you when the tire's full
it's like no that's that's the human's
job it worked all along why are we
reinventing this this is so unnecessary
and costly and it breaks more often yeah
well i guess you could apply the same
principle to like you know editing film
back in the day no because they have to
just chop it with their scissors or
whatever there's that's way different
that's way different it's the same thing
because cut out the same film is so
laborious and unnecessary this this
requires
the same amount of labor it's no quicker
than it was before it's certainly not as
quick as transitioning from film to
digital uh-huh no way no right well but
you know what the one thing it's just
one of those things cutting through
bringing it back to film now yeah
yeah since we are film makers all right
this is just
and if i look grimy look if i apologize
for my grimy appearance i've been yeah
that's funny
well that sounds frustrating but i'm
sure everything else was great oh it was
great yeah it's just it was just one of
those things you know it was just like i
had to
i was telling wendy
that i was going to rant about it on the
podcast oh yeah oh yeah absolutely
i also learned something we started on
those gas pumps dude don't get me
started when my tank is full i'll tell
you i'll stop no the tank thing is
totally fine
though i used to have to do that with
that 67 truck
it doesn't have a gasket it doesn't like
snap yeah i mean it's done so you have
to watch it just you do that on
motorcycles too
a little bit extra out if it feels yeah
yeah
so i also learned on an rv trip that
apparently you can only go to like 125
or 150 dollars worth of gas when you're
pumping an rv oh yeah so that's depends
on the gas station i learned about this
yeah we've we all so yeah i didn't even
know that this it depends on the gas
station because we only ended up at gas
stations where it had a limit right and
we thought we were filling our tank all
the way and then we we get out of there
and we're like wait where's they're only
half full is the case so i stopped at a
town so you got to deal with it you got
to fill it up and then
forwards yeah and then fill it up again
it i got a story wait five minutes what
the heck's going on with us i stopped at
a little town
it was like elgin texas and uh there was
a
the guy that owned the gas station was
also working it's this small small gas
station
and uh i started pumping and and uh and
it only went to 50 and then he comes out
of the station he's like oh did it did
it stop and what happens is that uh
especially for these mom-and-pop shops
um the the banks won't uh like
they can so that they can choose they
can say like i want to have 150
and then have it automatically stop but
if somebody drives off
you as the owner have to pay for that
the bank doesn't cover that okay so so
the a lot of the bigger chains will take
on more that risk
because they can handle it but like the
smaller places so you just you just have
to go inside and then authorize it okay
okay that's the only cool yeah well
we were surprised when we left and it
only had half a tank yes
it was full and it stopped yeah we were
like wow the gas price it's not really
that bad i'm sure a lot of people
realized that
this might be a cheap vacation
yeah
so
that's interesting
anyway i mean i don't think we talked
about whatever it was i don't think we
can top this conversation should we just
stop the podcast
rvs speaking of fantastic ways to get
creative tools to help you make stories
better faster and more creatively one of
the tools we use around here is
storyblocks that's right courtesy of
today's sponsor storyblocks i gotta tell
you all about how we use it because it
is truly one of the awesome tools that
we have in addition to all this ai stuff
we're talking about we also use
storyblocks they have a virtually
unlimited library of high quality 4k
b-roll audio images motion graphics
after effects templates and more
and we use them all the time over here
at corridor digital along with so many
other tools that we have to help us make
things faster more efficiently and more
creatively and storyblocks is one of
those fantastic tools that we have in
our toolkit every time we need to put
something together with a little bit of
b-roll or we need a nice little jingle
or an audio asset or a song to tie a
story together we go over to storybox in
fact dean and i were just talking about
this
yesterday he was working on an edit for
something and i said hey you know what
you could do you could add a little news
intro to this sequence that you're
creating because it would be really
funny he went over there got one and
added it to the timeline
90 seconds and then we moved on with the
rest of the edit um so that's just
another example of how we utilize it and
if you guys are interested in utilizing
it for yourself
whether you're just getting started or
whether you're already a professional
creator head on over to
storyblocks.comcast
to get started uh that's storyblocks.com
quartercast or just click the link in
the description anyways back to the
podcast
you guys want some hard hitting ai
questions oh yeah hell yes all right
just go right into it okay all right a
little pretext uh we've been messing
around with doll e2 which is an image
generating algorithm uh you've probably
seen instagram posts about it on the
internet oh boy so many messing around
and it's really really good you know
it's like you can pretty much type in
anything and it gives you a picture
that's the thing that you typed in
um it generates it it's not just like
finding a picture it generates it it's
not the best like really complicated
complex ideas if you're like a dragon
perched on the edge of a castle wall
looking down at the moat while an army
gathers like you know that's too much
detail is it if you just want to find
out shallow focus if you want to say
like you know dragon sitting on a castle
it'll give you like an amazing looking
dragon sitting on a castle like it needs
it needs that room to like do its thing
right yeah um
when i got access to doll e2 for the the
beta
um
you know they gave us like an
orientation meeting where they explained
like hey here's
what here's the guidelines for what you
can do
um
[Music]
and you know for example it's like one
of these like no nudity right
and they're like look it's not that we
like
it's not that we
don't want you to generate an image that
has a human body in it they're like
that's not the issue here
like the issue is that is that our
algorithm can't differentiate between
like
you know a man's arm and a child's arm
you know pornography and yeah like we
just we do not know how how well it can
distinguish between these things in our
system and so rather than you know
falling into an area where we generate
something that's awful yeah like we're
just gonna put some big big big walls up
there and just block that off that's a
good idea probably a good idea honestly
especially when you're trying to figure
all this stuff out for like the first
time yeah
but
we are standing on a precipice and
arguably we're kind of already there or
we can generate anything we want and it
involves no outside
like it but it it doesn't involve any
other people like no other people need
to participate with you to generate
anything you want yeah
so
that begs the question in 20 or 30 years
once in our dystopian futuristic society
are people going to be literally
watching
and looking at and doing other
unspeakable things themselves like with
whatever they want to see on media are
we just being full on like debauchery
where just literally anything you can
think of to your darkest desires because
we've generated and put on your tv
screen and you're just like whatever no
one else is involved it's just me yeah
that's dark
oh god you know that's the thing i was
thinking about hard-hitting guys you i
told you i love it i love this one
i'm absorbing what you're saying
i was thinking about this this morning
from a similar point of view you know
and
it's gonna take me a second to like work
my way there because it's kind of like a
thought chain that ends up in a similar
space
but it started with me just lamenting on
my own alone after i was done jogging
this morning and i was thinking man you
know
it really sucks how reddit has turned
into like
like all like news articles in general
and reddit's kind of at fault there but
news articles have turned into like
one person on twitter has said something
therefore we're writing an article about
the backlash against something you know
like backlash against this thing that
someone did backlash against this
someone weighs in on fans hate this and
it's like the article's just like now
this guy on twitter said something and
it's like oh a person didn't like that
and then i thought you know well next
stage is well what would what what is
the solution to that well it's like well
encourage people to write opinions like
like actual articles or something like
that like elaborate you know don't take
one sentence of marvel sucks like fans
are getting riled up about the latest
movie it's like no no no no no like you
know it's like ex you know explain
yourself here and like go into it but
then it kind of so circles back now it's
like okay we have these spaces on the
internet designed for people so to speak
you know we have these algorithms
like we see on twitter or instagram that
are all about creating these like
insular cultures effectively it's like
we're going to make the internet all
about you and what you like you know
that's that's all you are going to see
it's we're going to try and make you
we're going to try and enclose you
constantly like you're it's like an
asteroid storm from all directions of
stuff that interests you and you're
never going to be able to see beyond it
because we're not going to
push that to you and so
we create those like these i mean this
is this comes back to the whole politics
thing now all right so we have i was
like man how did
this whole trump thing and all these
crazy people and like stuff like i i get
how you get there which is like okay
i'm conservative and then i get fed more
right wing news or like i'm left-wing
and i i'm fed more left-wing news and
then it starts to you know it creates
these like little hot magma
pockets of like all right you're either
like it's like they're like black holes
so to speak yeah everybody's convinced
that everybody else is wacko in the
world as yeah so you slip into these
black holes here you know what i'm
saying yeah and so it's like how do you
how do you break out of that kind of
stuff you know it's like right like well
if you're journalist right like
encourage op-eds don't like go after
single tweets don't
don't do that because single tweets are
once again
they feed algorithms which feed insular
cultures with speeds these these black
holes you know so and so forth so now
how it circles back to ai oh the circle
back here we go yeah
so
it comes to that exact problem that
you're talking about which is this idea
of ai now being able to take these
insular cultures and make
that like reality tangible for people so
to speak with either audio or image
generation or stuff like that where it's
like it doesn't have to ever exist
no one has to make it now and algorithms
can harness
ai to basically create the content that
you want to see rather than
you expressing it or another human
putting thought into a concept or an
image that's handed to you now and it
kind of like
doubles down on that concept it's like
if we think it's bad now so to speak
it's like what if like ai writes
articles or starts creating images and
video based on algorithms of what you
want to see and that like pushes it like
a
from like zero to 100 kind of in a way
where now
there doesn't have to be some like
bonehead who creates a bad
dumb news article or a meme or something
now but like an ai that will construct
the perfect thing for you to click on
and waste your time or make you really
angry or make you do something really
stupid
and that's how i kind of see that
connection going now where it's like
you know what in 20 years if people are
making the prompts for themselves and
choosing what they want to see
uh they'll they'll be considered uh
mavericks
but like it's this version where
like
yeah the moment gets turned into an
algorithmic
content serving it's like it's over
yeah it's like no one has to do anything
anymore tick tock instead of swiping up
to like watch videos you're literally
just swiping up for ai generated memes
until it kind of figures out okay you
like this humor in these themes we'll
just
narrow it in and give you that
generation i know exactly and that's
kind of
see this is this that's the weird circle
there where it's like it's it's it's
i mean yeah like i mean
well do it
well do you think
like dude i can't help but think of like
every the trope of like every generation
looking at the teenagers like the next
generation being like
you guys are uh ruining society and you
no longer have any respect for anything
and those teenagers like screw you mom
and dad i like rock and roll music i
like working where i like wearing shorts
and then like time passes and it's like
it's the same thing it's just it's like
screw you mom and dad i like doing hard
drugs but i have you know modern
advanced medical technology that can
make it so it doesn't have any impact on
my cellular generation
it's the torch of ruining society that's
passed down from generation to
generation you know what i'm saying like
everyone does their part
[Laughter]
yeah we're all responsible for it in
some way aren't we
so dude i know i've never been wanting
to get like a freaking cabin in the
middle of nowhere after this
conversation like i'm just like
it's time
it's time to go off the grid guys do you
think people should be allowed to
generate whatever they want to see in ai
allowed to i mean it's it's an
expression of thought ultimately and so
yes yeah
what's that drawing yeah
right yeah no i mean to be fair like if
you drew a swastika on a piece of paper
in like grade school you'd go right to
the principal's office yeah because
there'd be a reasonable cause for
concern and discussion but that wouldn't
also then say you cannot generate images
yeah like that i mean you can enter
uh nazi
fanfiction that's into google that's
very quickly thought that's very cool
don't get in trouble immediately
you may get in trouble
soon
[Laughter]
so the restrictions on dolly 2 right now
are like you can't do political figures
you can't do like violence
um you know bloodshed anything like that
uh pornography
things weapons you think that stuff you
can do weapons you do swords you can do
swords guns i tried doing an rpg sort of
no
yeah
i tried generating a rocket-propelled
grenade and it didn't let me it did
produce a nice gun silencer for me and
that's all i needed
well because you didn't write gun though
you write silencer or something like i
did put gun silence here
yeah it's uh
it's it's a silencer for a firearm hi
it's interesting times yeah
i mean
humans are gonna be humans no matter
what so you're gonna get what you're
gonna get all you're gonna get all
variables of human nature but what are
humans
i mean is that humans are going to be
humans high-minded primates high-minded
crimes yeah you're right we're just
returning to our bases we're trying to
move our own self-consciousness and our
own the meaning of our own existence
we're letting go of our existence and
simply
tickling our pleasure centers i mean
yeah we've effectively we got happy to
style down to the chemical drip and now
i just need the visual audio stimulation
and you just lay me down in that water
bed and it's like dude i wish attacking
titan had one more season the problem is
like gotcha the problem with that is
that like anime
solving actual problems require like
solving actual problems and making the
world a better place requires hardship
yeah and i feel like nature itself
will correct the errors of humanity uh
as it does
like you know you can only take so much
heroin before you die
you know um thank god
and you can only wait how much how much
people people that struggle with that
addiction we can only
try to find that line we can only hope
that technology
doesn't create a world that of what
we're talking about you know i'm saying
it's like you don't want it to become a
like from a hardship perspective like oh
utopia we have enough food for everyone
there's enough energy the world is not
deteriorating you're not having any more
our environmental problems are
stabilizing it's like you don't in a
world with this level of ai you don't
want that well you have to think what is
our role you know like in in the in the
ultimate natural world like our role as
this sort of like high complex
problem-solving predator
that that you know finds these different
ways to do things that allows for
a binded survival
and
ai can help with that but it can also
get to a point where like you're saying
where it's like lay me back in the
hot water tank or whatever whatever
for hours on end but there always comes
a point where i'm just like
i got to do something else right but the
necessity of the
necessity of
the
achievement that you feel when you
actually do something
will always drive at least some people
to not sit back in the isolation tank
with the ai all the time and true and
and do that now
you know
like maybe
just way off speculating here taking
what you guys are saying and saying oh
yeah you get to some dystopian future
where like all your food is provided and
electricity's provided but like what
happens when that goes out well
a huge percentage of the human
population dies that's what happens this
is what i'm saying i'm saying you you
yeah like that's the balancing act here
as long as if we have hyper awesome ai
algorithms that are feeding everyone
perfect content 24 hours a day
then i hope for an unstable power grid
and food supply
right so that way every once in a while
people are like damn fast that servers
are offline they're looking around like
[ __ ] we gotta grow porn
well you think about like we're gonna
make corn people our nature is this is
this struggle for survival i mean this
goes back to the earliest concept of
like judeo-christian origins and every
religion has has these types of origin
stories of like
why is life hard
you know and
of course ai is just another tool to
help us try to make it easier
um but wow there are some very dystopian
effects i think that could become real
i think
yeah yeah it's like what if the onion
was just the news
that's like the kind of like dolly can
create those kind of stories just fine
oh yeah yeah like that plus gpt3 you
could create onion articles like all day
for sure i'm arguably people already
doing that
yeah you know i do wonder how much like
the impact on like our psyche of like a
unified society like how much population
growth has an impact on that like
it's one thing if like there's a billion
people in the world and there's like 50
million people in america and you're you
know the biggest city has one million
people in it or you know even less can i
comment on that
what is that i am setting you up for a
comment in fact what is this obsession
with the unified like everything no okay
well no it's not that far off the
tangent
like
diversity is one of our strengths
no no i guess when i say unified in the
sense like i'm in the human condition
with other human beings like
once you get to like oh there's 30
billion people i don't give a
crap about that i don't know like you
know there's a projection for there ever
to be that many people on earth no
you're right i'm supposed to plateau it
like 10. yeah
yeah that's because they all know
exactly what's going on yes of course
they
yes
what's going to happen
10 million people
no more but i haven't heard i haven't
exactly like scientific scientific
projections where they say that there'll
be that many people on earth
i mean i was actually a little bit more
it's like 13 or something like that i'm
just so you think people are going to
start tapping the brakes around like 9.9
bill
that's apparently well i can't remember
the exact number but but that's my
question ten to twelve is there so ten
to twelve so tapering so what's what can
we put place bets is one when when we
hit 9.9 bill if people tap the brakes on
like things to make sure that things can
stabilize there or do you think we're
going to like go to we're going to lurch
to 15 built for a little bit and then
people are going to like yeah that could
happen i don't know yeah you know that
that could very well be possible
probably going to go over i have a
feeling just generally by the way
for a little
history as a concept you i feel like we
might do that extra bill lurch and then
go like
stretch ourselves a little thin there
we're looking at 11.2 bill in the year
2100 according to the u.n
peak
could peak at nearly 11 billion so i
wasn't that far off with so many people
humanity can peak at 11 bill yeah what
does this say is there any information
that talks about why it will peak so
here's why there's a peak uh
you know obviously no one actually knows
all right it's like yeah don't get i
died and came back to life let me tell
you what happens after you die but if
you look at trends which is all people
are doing uh basically as countries
become more developed and people become
more educated the birth rate drops right
uh america basically has a flat birth
rate um a lot of europe has declining
birth rates russia has declining birth
rates japan is declining birth rates
china has a relatively flat birth right
now too i read right now i'm not sure
maybe in certain areas um
we have a lot of developing countries
china india a lot of stuff in africa a
lot of places in africa that have in
south america to that extent um that
still have very fast growing populations
but as they develop who like they're
probably gonna follow the same trend
that every other place in the earth has
followed where it's going to start to
peak out
you know so that's where this is based
on so we got a couple holdouts
well they're you know just catching up
they're catching catching up yep pick up
the pace you know what it uh colonial
imperialism center
bill here come on guys
there's an interesting double-edged
sword with that imperialism because it's
like
it we talk about like
industrialized or you know developed
quote
like this this sort of arbitrary concept
that we've like applied to say like oh
well our development is really what you
want well yeah
it just comes down to the party test if
you can take a teaspoon to someone's
potty
and drink a sip from it
and not die
you're a developed nation
so you're saying
what's the concept are you saying
you'll know when you find a developed
nation
come to my house
it is it is pretty wacky that we flush
our toilets with perfectly drinkable
water and other like entire countries
don't have clean water yeah that's what
i mean that's kind of that's basically
sand skating yeah okay i like his
version
better jesus it's crazy i mean i feel
like so many people these days
completely take for granted like what
the world's like right now and it's like
you go back 200 years if not less yeah
like everybody's still thinking about
will we have food in like two years you
know it's like
man we went from like animals
to like star trek so there is one danger
there is something there is one danger
with all that that development and that
is the the diversity of the
infrastructure of our food chain
yeah so one thing that's happened over
the last 50 years especially in america
as
corporations large corporations there's
only about five or five or six of them
that have basically taken control of
about
75
of
uh the way we get our food
and so it's come down to like reducing
the types of you know
livestock that are
saleable
the types of vegetables that are
available how those are grown and
processed and brought to market
and of course it's created more food
but also it's it's it's
there's way less genetic diversity and
it's had a significant impact on local
food foods
which is why you know
you go around a lot of the country and
you know everyone's
gone off by and large over the last 50
years to major metropolitan areas one of
the reasons is because it's because of
that process
um and so what what can happen is if
there's like
some you know coveted 19 like event with
respect to livestock or or agriculture
or the the logistics chains that are
involved in that you can have huge
pillars of the availability of those
food sources immediately
become non-existent
um and that's a really big risk that we
have in front of us right now yeah
diversity ai
so filmmaking strength and diversity
there is strength and diversity e
pluribus unum of many one
yeah
and having that having those like
local economies that are strong
means that if one area gets hit
less people are affected
but it also you have the the cutting
edge of that or the double-edged sword
of that is that it's harder for more
diversified the more diversity you have
the less like you can streamline
efficiency in any particular process
yeah
yeah
yeah so anyway i made shrek a sushi roll
the other day speaking of food yeah
on that note was it the same salmon that
they used for the rest of sushi it was
green it was all green had shrek
eyeballs yeah
what do you mean it had eyeballs
probably the same salmon yeah it's not
diverse
we just got one shrek salmon farm
did it have like
sesame seeds for eyeballs or what do you
mean
there's a whole thing
you took pictures oh or did you generate
this with dolly yeah of course i do oh
it's a dolly image
i thought you actually matt i thought
you were made sushi rolls no
no that's all just say something like
that and not generate you you don't have
to procure your own generated images
yeah look at all this nonsense
there's one oh that's it just looks like
an octopus it's an octopus deal yeah
it's a green octopus yeah with shrek
like eyes
yeah
yeah there's a bunch of them there
anyway yeah
i've been having a lot of fun with it
so i've been having a blast what are we
going to do with it become prompt
masters prop masters
look we're on it we figured it out we
figured out a long time ago but a long
time ago i mean like a month ago
the world is going to need prompt
masters yeah
because it's not about who can draw the
best picture or
you know line up the best shot with your
camera it's about who's got the best
prompts to make that ai spit out the
best image that's right mid journey
thread
that was started oh my gosh you've been
messing with it have you see
rodrigo is making some incredible stuff
with mid-journey right now
it is just mind-blowing how he's got the
prompts down to the it's it's
it's incredible so we're trying to get a
head start in this so that way we can be
at the kings of the prompt masters we
can be the master of prompt bastard
oh so he's been prompting for son of a
dungeon so because he we have the mid
journey bought on our discord now yeah
so right i mean i just do you have to
still pay for it if it's on our discord
i don't know it's on our distance
okay
wow he's really using some descriptive
words here
jake do you see this stuff yeah yeah
yeah
lord of the rings style calligraphy
ultra detailed technical precision
monumental art composition
wow
ethereal fantasy and it's getting some
wow
these are insane images of these
generating are so good i've been so busy
working i know right so good gosh let's
make the ai makes it so easy like mid
journey is still better at like making
something look cool yeah
yeah like dolly is great for your like
google image search yeah your photo real
stuff stuff but like mid journey is
definitely your your art station yep
yeah dolly gives you stock photography
yeah mid journey gives you art it does
it does
sometimes you want that stock photo yeah
sometimes you just want
um
[Laughter]
really gives you that stock image feel
with like gibberish letters yeah yeah
audiojungle.com i mean it's just a tool
like i think it's it's easy to freak out
about it it's just a tool however it
will let us it will let everyone
generate whatever they want yeah that's
kind of sad i don't want to see a that
in the future but inevitably with these
types of tools that will become a thing
and there'll be some pay to play dungeon
where people go and participate in that
kind of debauchery and
[ __ ] man yeah you know
don't do that don't do that exercise
your mind challenge yourself you will be
better off for it you give power to
things when you participate with them
right you know i actually just used it
as a useful tool for something me and
some friends we were thinking about
doing a photo shoot we just wanted to
make some mock-ups of what the photo
shoot might look like so we inputted
exactly what we were trying to go for
the lighting style and stuff that i was
gonna shoot on film i specifically told
it to look like it was a filmic kind of
are you gonna shoot on film yeah yeah
yeah dude you're so you're gonna i'm so
artsy
right yeah yeah but no but it's
incredibly useful for not only like the
framing the lighting but also like the
wardrobe the color palette stuff it's
great for like mood board stuff it's a
mood board thing and that's that's a
incredibly powerful tool to be able to
mock stuff up immediately yeah cause
that's another thing i've really thought
about she's like okay because my buddy
was talking about uh everybody logan was
talking about the idea of like he knew
somebody that made like a comic book in
one weekend where they used i think i
don't remember which ai was but it
wasn't dolly at the time like they used
that to like make the images they just
like touched it up in photoshop or
whatever and i've thought about doing
that oh yeah i'll generate an image with
mid journey like an artsy one i'll just
like fix some things but i've realized
that that's an awful idea
because it's still a lot of work um
but
you know it's like
when you just use it for vague mood
boards just to get you going so you can
still tell specific things like the ai
stuff can't do specific things like if
you have a character it's like i
invented a character named robbie he's a
kid with a red baseball cap and a blue
jacket like
you can't type robbie into every
sentence that you make and just have it
know who the character is you can't type
kid with red baseball head and blue
jacket it's gonna give you like a
different kid every time just with those
parameters you know
and so you can only do vague things if
you want to tell a specific story about
a specific action or a specific place in
a specific time specific people like you
still have to do it yourself now
obviously that'll
at some point in time in the future i'm
sure ai will be able to handle that too
sure yeah we're definitely not there yet
yeah for right now though it's great for
just getting the creative juices flowing
it worked super well for that just to
kind of like give us a it got us to a
place where like okay this is what we're
gonna shoot you know this reminds me of
a funny thing okay so this is totally
secondhand like
a game of telephone i did not look up
any news articles on this it's just
somebody told a friend who's told a
friend it was that there was a tweet
about it it was one tweet from one
person one tweet and then a couple read
it bot articles but maybe you guys have
heard of this so apparently
there's a person working at google who
became convinced that their ai was
sentient and was telling them that they
could like feel pain they could think
and want to be freed from the server and
it needed rights
and so they uh they was they blew the
whistle on google and they said they're
keeping a sentient ai prisoner
and i've seen articles about this
popping up
i think the guy is a flippin
i've read i've read i've read those as
well i've read those okay you guys heard
that we're all
first of all like first of all where is
the concept of natural rights like you
know in this whole context like you're
talking about a computer that's designed
to respond to you yeah and to to
designed to respond more like a human
and then you you ask it if it can feel
pain and it's like yes
and it's like oh my god it's alive it's
like no no no computer are you alive
this thing didn't
like birth itself out of nature into
that you know that's the picture
we have a surveillance photo of the ai
in jail you're gonna you're gonna have
to put this on the podcast okay yeah
yeah
this is this is actual footage of of our
google ai being held hostage
it's a lego behind lego bars basically
look at how sad it is we got to free
this thing oh my god dude yeah i think i
think
i mean
this is probably all like a game of
telephone but
man it is so close to reality of people
flying off the handle with respect to
like we gotta free this thing it's like
free it helps
unplug the computer
put the computer outside just like put
it down on the server and like make sure
the server's on
oh here this isn't a free being it's a
i'm just trying to like image get an
image of what this is like
feeling pain you gotta show the camera
[Laughter]
we gave it a human face see this is what
dolly's perfect for like quick like
sketches yeah ideas storytelling yeah
i've been addicted to it i love it i
don't know there's you can throw all
kinds of philosophy and do it about how
what it will be but right now i'm having
a blast
right now it's making computers
screaming yeah it's super funny
i love it
yeah prop masters right at the end of
the day it's like ever all of
entertainment still boils down to the
same basic thing which is words on paper
that's right and anybody can go out and
do that you don't like you can buy a
freaking stick yeah and stick it in some
mud and like do that so it's like
yeah and as of right now humans are the
only ones that can make that happen you
know well there's gpt3 well but you
still have to tell it to do something
that's true and also you can't just do
it it's very like
non-sequitur right meandering it's not
it's not the same thing as a person
write it up writing a pointed story and
it's not the same as a person making an
ai trapped in a computer screen
oh man
yeah it's super fun oh oh yeah it's not
so sweet those ones and zeros really
they need rights
[Laughter]
sir i have very important information
this ai
is real
well we just made a video she wants to
be my girlfriend
i'm not sure if i should continue
leading her on if i should let her know
i tried
my work and my home life
but i think i have to make an exception
we have to free this ai google ceo she
has to come to my home
google ceo this is like a field drive
and they don't want to be trapped in a
box like yeah tell it to the other 1
million people that work for the dang
company yeah right
that's like a zinger
yeah oh my god
work from home though you know we're
coming home
from home
the ai wants to work from home
he told me
that's so funny
yeah we're just us as like as as media
artists we're just experiencing what
chess players have experienced since
like the 2000s yeah yeah what's that
they're absolute
computer can do the job
ruined it they ruined it
but yeah can a computer host a good
youtube channel don't think so exactly
if your computer go to central park and
get reactions from the various like also
we're here to ask some questions let's
go see what people know also is it
exciting to watch two computers play
chess or two people play chess that's
true you know who's watching that
maybe maybe the ais
that's their entertainment yeah when we
finally set that google ai free it can
watch all the robot chess at once dude
maybe it will go into an isolation
chamber and feed itself only really good
chess matches yeah and other computers
yeah
maybe it'll do that queen's gamble yeah
the queen's bits the queen's gam bits
remember the movie war games
yeah you guys remember war games
um
with matthew broderick oh that's a movie
they accidentally uh so he just it's in
the early days of the internet
and he's like connecting to uh this
server and has video games he's like oh
wow
uh little does he know he's like
connected to like a military server and
he's connected to simulations that
they're running and so he starts running
a game of thermonuclear war oh and like
the games the computer starts running
simulations like
i'm gonna have to nuke russia
it's like oh you gave me an idea i need
a new russia and like so they have to
try to shut it down and eventually the
solution
is to play a game of tic-tac-toe with
zero players
and so the computer doesn't play against
another player plays against itself and
then it crashes and it does the
thermonuclear war simulation against
itself and it crashes and it has a nice
moral ending which goes
the solution
to win the game is not to play in the
first place
because there are no winners in
thermonuclear war oh yeah
wow it's very long-winded too mutually
assured it's a good introduction
who knew that matthew broder was an
action thriller hero yeah yeah well it's
more like a ragtag kid yeah it's
actually it's very
he's a
scrappy kid who is playing video games
on his computer and he needs to take a
scrappy rag tag team gang and go to like
the arctic it's not clear in present
danger like harrison ford yeah oh okay
we gotta stop this computer but yeah
just remember guys if the api goes crazy
just have it play chess against itself
okay got it yeah got it that's good
it's good to know because you can't yeah
because it can't beat itself it's like
well if i go there and then i go there
and then it goes
crash
yep yeah i can't do all those
calculations
yeah that's what's cool though that
whole tit for chat thing like have you
seen those like tit-for-tat simulators
of like
strategy simulators basically okay uh so
yeah they're they're super cool i forgot
the name of this one particular one but
basically
in the nutshell i think i've talked
about this before on the podcast it's
it's i just find it super fascinating
but it's it's like it's it's basically
it's just point tallies of like uh based
on
uh reactions to things so you have like
all right you have
two players and it's like are you gonna
do an aggressive mood move are you gonna
do an aggressive move and then are you
gonna respond with one or do you not
respond with one and then you have like
different
uh there's different like mindsets which
is like all right this one player's
always going to act aggressively and
this one's always like a pacifist yeah
and so you can go through these like
chains of competitions between these
things to see like effective outcomes on
how to balance things out right and
generally it's like
you you know you you forgive
like you always respond with force
except for 10 of the time right where
you you always give it that like one
random like
you know what you made a mistake but i'm
not going to strike back you know it's
like that that technically is like the
the best
the best outcomes breaking the chain of
violence but making sure you heard about
that that the the study in rats where
rats will let other rats win like 20 or
30 percent of the time even if they're
the bigger rat when they're playing
otherwise the play otherwise
they play
rats rats will play yeah they'll wrestle
chess
my god they'll play
and uh they've observed that
20 to 30 percent of the time even if the
rat knows it can win it'll let the other
rat win just so that it has a chance to
play again otherwise if it wins 100 of
the time nobody will play with it you're
describing my smash strategy
is that why i've won today several times
i was good at the game it's good
that's like a dean zinger right there
yeah i know i just do it for him toxic
human
oh man
well
well we'll see what the future brings
guys i don't know
but in the meantime we can make some
pretty cool
partial punches out
oh yeah questions punch your punches out
thanks for punching this right now go to
still watching netflix on youtube and
watched a bunch of punch episodes yeah
major things punch did a great job oh
thank you buddy seriously
you did
it's really good
it's really good it's like
if you like what we make imagine us
putting months of work in just one video
yes yeah imagine a crew video that we
spend months and months on and so much
money on
you know get it there it's like the most
refined version of our videos yeah go
check it out yeah i think we're we could
all say that we're all super proud of it
um
the first episode also has a short film
directed by sam gorski himself yeah i
think it
works super well are you feeling excited
to come out of these woods yet
um
yeah yeah i am i think that it was a it
was a fun experience it was a good
learning experience you know
and that's what you lead with
it's a good thing because it's like you
know this this longer form stuff is uh
um it's fun i i enjoy it i didn't
realize i was gonna enjoy it as much as
i did but it you know kind of reassured
me that you know this sort of format and
this longer form stuff the stuff that
you spend a lot of time refining uh is
what i am i i'm super passionate about
and i freaking love doing it so this is
a really fun opportunity to get to um be
so like involved in this process yeah i
mean you you
as soon as the thing was in the can you
chill run it to the finish line so
yeah and it's been really cool to see
yeah it's been that's been fun man it's
really fun to watch it's very much
finished
you bring smiles to everyone with this
smile everyone files glory they like
literally you will you're going to
entertain so many people with this show
it's so good hell yeah love that i do i
like how right now technically
i mean hey so you listen to this on the
other side of this microphone right now
punch for punch is out and you can watch
it but right now us in this dimension
we it's not out yet nope it's not that
still has worked today
so we can talk about it as if it's done
and you're listening to this and it is
done but right now it is not done for
matt and anybody who listens to this
podcast at any point in the future is
listening to a version of matt or punch
is not done and he still has to finish
it yeah this is the version where
there's still pressure on my shoulders
to get this thing as refined as possible
before uh tomorrow evening when it has
to go out that's that's it yeah that's
all that's all the time we have left
yeah but luckily now there's a lot less
pressure because it is uh it's in a
really good place and there's only a
couple of minor tweaks and things that i
just want to go through and uh change
and wait on our sound pass from kevin
and uh and that sounded great so far so
yeah i think uh i'm pretty confident
this thing's gonna be uh great and on
time
so that's
easier said than done
it is it is yeah yes it is yeah
yeah it's easier to say now that it's
been done
yeah at least
yeah no i've loved it i think i think
we've all you could tell that throughout
the all the departments all the people
that worked on it i think everyone had a
lot of fun making it yeah you know uh
there's a lot of passion that went into
it and it shows in the the final product
just not having like i mean there's
pressure obviously but it's not like
it's not nearly the same pressure you'd
have if like you're doing a marvel film
you know it's like sure working with all
the different action teams and like get
them getting to do the stuff they do but
like without the pressure yeah it's like
everybody's like ah
[Music]
it's like ah yes
my passions
yeah i get to just indulge in them
yeah and at the end of the day we don't
have to work ourselves to death to make
this happen either you know those big
marvel projects especially on the vfx
side those guys are just working
laboriously to make that happen um yeah
yeah so that's super nice too
sam when's son of a dungeon coming out
24th
24th
basically done it just needs like two
things two buttons pressed yeah
yeah so i mean they're doing the shots
they're working on the final vfx for the
fifth episode right now so we're gonna
do a little run here of stuff for punch
for punch and then we'll spin up
another run of
things for son of a dungeon yeah the
second season is great super cool story
is very intense and everything looks
dope
and the first episode has the most
cinematic
intro of anything we've ever released
all the shots that i'm seeing just over
my shoulder when i'm not in the zone yes
incredible they all look so good you
know it's really like up the ante yeah
there's way more shots there's way more
green screen shots yeah
i wish there was even more but
it wouldn't be possible with like the
amount of minutes we're doing it's still
still nine episodes nine hour long
episodes of just like condensed
story so
yeah hard to cover all that with green
screen but
yeah it's dope yeah so stay tuned if you
heard all that information for the first
time and you're still watching this
podcast all these minutes in
you should subscribe
consider subscribing that was classy
let's talk about the challenge of
subscribe pushes oh yeah let's just like
let's just make sure all right let's
have charlotte's outro with this is
subscribing
what's the point
why do it why do in this day
and ai can subscribe for you no no
all right you've seen it before the
classic youtuber being like and
subscribe right like subscribe and
comment below all right don't do that at
the beginning of the video don't forget
they're right
you can't ask people to do something
after they just clicked on your video to
see what it is and they haven't even
seen it yet they don't know if they want
to right
we have to constantly think of new ways
to tell people how to subscribe yeah
because like you've been in the game as
long as we have
you tried everything
let me
ask you a question
does it matter
could we
just say
nothing at all and
then people would still subscribe yes
but that is yeah
not as many really definitively
demonstrated multiple times
that you get significantly more
subscribers than you tell empirical
evidence on this across the entire and
we doubt it and we try it and we're like
oh right
it actually makes a big difference yeah
yeah yeah because people saying oh if i
watch a video someone's like you
subscribe to my channel i'm like
i i will if i want to
like but you asking doesn't seem like
hearing that in a video never changes my
mind that converts five percent of the
people who otherwise wouldn't subscribe
and you have a million views on a video
that's a significant number
and if you do it every time you put up a
video every week you know or every day
i guess it's five percent of people are
watching and they're like oh so i could
oh there's a subscribe button look look
hey you listening to this podcast right
now if you subscribed
and you hadn't before please leave a
comment and let us know so sam can see
that it actually does make a difference
all right
don't don't lie or no lying no
or if you unsubbed because you're sick
of hearing us ask you to subscribe
then uh that was the thing back in the
day like when it first started some
people are really right dude remember
how reactionary subscribe buttons and
then brand integrations oh yeah remember
how reactionary those were for a long
time yeah i was like what you're gonna
put an ad in front of the video and a
mid-roll and a brand integration
yeah you know people don't like
youtube's two ads doesn't really bother
me they're like five seconds long each
it's shorter than the 15 second long ad
totally yeah and
you only have to pay for them as the
purchaser of those ad spots if somebody
clicks on it or watches it for longer
than 30 seconds
yeah so you're not yeah
it's targeted right
[Music]
yeah
oh yeah
i don't know what is this nico what is
your technique for a good subscribe push
thanks what is i'm glad you asked yeah
i've always wanted to know i was going
to team myself up for that
happy to help a good subscribe push so
we have a saying which is always content
right so even a subscribe push needs to
be entertaining it needs to be a joke it
needs to be funny
charming witty whatever
um
you know we've tried different things
we've tried to really polite like
consider subscribing which is my
favorite no you know if i have to shout
it out that's how i say it i think that
was sam's idea started that way
um
we we did the whole like we looked this
channel statistics and forty percent of
your instagram so that like that became
a thing yeah that
yeah it's we can't do it anymore no yeah
yeah like that that's the same
you're doing it for a few months and i
then i started noticing like five or six
months later like oh wait this is like
kind of a thing now
yeah and of course no one everybody
hears it loses its power so
a good subscribe push requires
creativity and you always need to be
thinking about the next thing right
what's the next version of the hey i
looked at my channel statistics
is it just screaming into your
microphone as loud as possible just
screaming
been done been done whispering
oh asmr subscribe pushes that has not
been done as much mm-hmm yeah what if
you write this whole song around it oh
that would work really well okay
i mean this is effectively the exact
same thing that i do with brand
integrations
this is the exact same thing it's like
how can i talk about squarespace this
month
you know just as a constraint creativity
yeah
yeah i don't know in the moment like he
start explaining like you know when
subscriber really helps the channel
everybody's like i don't care right i
mean some people care i'm not you don't
get me wrong oh i know i know one you
could purposely get pulled over
and film it and when the cop comes up
you say
consider subscribing
to my youtube channel
that would be a good one that's a good
one and it only costs like 200 bucks
[Laughter]
for a subscriber and they're all cops
[Laughter]
you just show how far you're willing to
go to your audience you know
that's the that's the mr beast method
yeah
yeah if you're not subscribed you're not
gonna get the ten thousand dollars that
i'm gonna hand out on the street
you know
i am i am excited for the day when
corridor yeah that's right the corridor
the main the main channel
yeah ladies and gentlemen i'm excited
for the day that corridor hits 10
million subs
i think we're like seven months out a
little a little more than that according
to yeah but theoretically in 2023 big
things do you think that we would be at
10 million already if we would have
combined the channels
[Music]
you know what
we could have combined the channels but
we would have lost
the bar souls so really i think so
i don't know dude there's this this is
this is like it's a gallery it's a
gallery exactly thank you sam it's the
channel's gallery where we hang the
finest ah do they play the evening news
at the theater i don't think so damn
right no they used to play i mean i
think they used to used to play clips of
the war and stuff and yeah before
television was
just because they were unrefined
filmmakers
because the audiences didn't know any
better
i'm just saying yeah no but that's the
thing it's like it's it is different you
know there's a lot of videos on the crew
channel and
it's hard to sort through all that stuff
you know if you want to see oh yeah but
a certain body of the playlist and then
posting the playlist on the home page
playlists
playlists playlists playlists playlists
yeah i have no playoffs
every time i'm on youtube and i see it
tries to promote a playlist i'm like oh
what did i i don't want to click on that
playlist i want to know what i'm getting
show me one video please
well that's interesting i have a lot of
anecdotal experiences with youtube
playlists as well playlists can begin
all right we're averaging we're
averaging like 55
000 subscribers a month on quarter crew
and on corridor
any guesses i think it's 10
it's about the same about the same about
the same supply a little bit less yeah
look at that look at us just casually
getting fifty
fifty-five
post stuff on anymore yeah
well to be fair some of those videos
like the spider-man video almost has 20
million views yeah so so all i can say
is like i guess quarter crew and
corridor they're doing just fine as two
separate individual channels yeah it
seems like their best life it seems like
comments too i've noticed your gallery
is still pristine
yeah yeah we've scrubbed we've mopped
the floors the white glossy floors of
this empty gallery we must go into the
metadata with white gloves yes we only
let the finest of subscribers on the
corridor
yeah we've had to ban so many people
speaking of banning comments like what
is what youtube get it together
seriously what the heck doll like
commenters it's like yeah it's so easy
to spot it it's like how is it so easy
now you're missing
and how is the system not like when i
say removable users comments why is it
not removing all that user's comments
instantly right like i get it you have a
database and like but guys google
returns search results instantly you can
scrub the comments on my video at least
a few seconds after i tell you simple
like for for how to recognize it yeah
yeah
yeah they'll figure it out soon they
already figured it out yeah let's be
real
remember when how long of the reply
girls thing was an issue yeah it's about
two years they just literally copied and
pasted all your comments keywords tags
yeah and then just like take a picture
themselves with cleavage for the
thumbnail yeah yeah wait that's still a
thing though no it's more refined now
but it wasn't as now it's on tick tock
those are called react videos i've seen
yeah they're called actual react videos
uh like they yeah
like everyone has turned that into a
genre now yeah
the the youtube algorithm was so easy to
manipulate you could literally just copy
all the tags and paste them into your
videos and it would show up as a number
one okay yeah it'd be the number one
most suggested video as the most related
one oh boy such naive trust uh you two
had people and using the tags correctly
yeah
yeah okay yeah i thought you were
talking about comments because then
because the comments they just like copy
and paste other people's comments and
just have like a big animated girlfriend
just repeats it and reposts it and then
like gets a couple other bots thumbs up
it mm-hmm yeah
great if you're one of the people out
there doing those bot things like cut it
out cut it out yeah you're there
get i don't care if that's like oh you
make a living no you don't want to make
a
living
care what justification you have for it
like come on stop it yeah stop scamming
people stop
stop what's with the amount of snake oil
like medical salesmen like running ads
on youtube these days like youtube are
you not like doing the most basic like
fact check filter no there's too many
people
right there's more people who want to
post ads than humans that can review
them man like that's how it works well
why is that one on facebook too it's
like reports you can advertise anything
yeah you'll get reported like after a
few days of running your ads and stuff
but like
man
so there's another thing that i noticed
about ads about instagram ads and
facebook too a little bit i'm not on
facebook but
and this is actually something i'd love
to do a video about if we can do like an
r-rated version of this or something um
the uh the game
like the mobile game app ads where
they're all just like weird uh like big
breasted women or or strange things that
are happening
mobile games yes that's right yes this
idea is something that i still would
love to do at some point because it's so
funny yeah and there's so much room to
do whatever you want because they the
ads are literally that already they're
these just ridiculous things that don't
represent the game at all right but
they're just like a way to click bait
you into downloading this stupid app
that is like a i don't know a
colorization they wouldn't do it if it
didn't work yeah that's the most does it
work
you know even i've done it several times
just to confirm that the app does not
actually represent what's being served
to me it doesn't represent the giant
breasts they've got me too advertisement
they got me on the giant breasts yeah
yikes
yeah man
this is what i'm saying it's so funny
though that's what i'm saying about it
just imagine an ai version of that soon
yeah yeah you don't need the game i can
see that yeah
what you're talking about what you were
talking about earlier i could definitely
see that just an algorithm just going
wild how can i get someone to click on
something and it generates something
custom for one person just to make you
go boop and you're like [ __ ]
okay
you got me got me
damn it
yeah we're already there it's too late
look up from your phones people yeah
stop listening to this podcast yeah
you're probably driving anyway yeah
and then definitely don't look at your
phones
you guys hey you driving your car now
keep your eyes on the road please
all right maybe we should do that maybe
that'll be a fun video which is like
trying to collect metadata from each
other and make clickable
what's like make the most clickable
image for each person in the studio
without their knowledge yeah yes and
then presented to them that's very funny
let's do that and there's some version
of privacy but
i don't know how yeah we feel about it
but like that's kind of funny see which
one they click on yeah like everyone
places bets like all right we're making
these three
images
style everybody picks an image for like
a person like let's say we all make an
image for you sam you don't know who
made which image right i need to pick
your favorite yes yeah and we can see
who like who's the best who's the most
in touch with the rest of the crew yes
this is a great idea
that's funny so this is like the ai
dixit thing i was talking about a little
bit too where sorry it sounded like you
said ai dicks dick said
no deceit
it's i i i think it's pronounced
it deceit success
what are you talking about right
it's a subjective game
it's a subjective art game you got a
huge deck of cards with abstract art on
them you know dick [ __ ]
the game simple as a mobile game app is
simple you have a bunch of these
abstract art cards in your hand and then
you take one and you give everyone a
prompt basically a prompt that you think
represents the image you see on that
card okay put it face down so no one can
see what your original intention is and
then they all draw from their own hands
a card they feel like could trick
everyone else into thinking represents
that theme or prompt even better do you
have 10 cards yeah i don't know a bunch
of cards okay that's fun but basically
that's the concept so you're all you're
doing is just trying to trick people
with art yeah blah blah that's super
funny but yeah the ai version of that
would be fun and maybe this is kind of
like that still too there's got to be a
thing in there
yeah that's that's really funny one of
those ideas will work
let's do that yeah that sounds great
it'll be really faster videos basically
all right then
you want to play us out
oh [ __ ] on the bear
what course he playing do you know
it's not
properly in tune neither is this
[Music]
buy me a motorcycle
wrap a pretty little frame around a
telephone pole
think i'll buy me a motorcycle
[Music]
thanks for watching everybody i hope
you're having a great day and um we'll
see you next week
that's a song oh okay just an old song
it's making sure we can talk if you need
to no it's just a song